>> I WANT TO GIVE YOU A CHANCE
TO CLEAR THE AIR ON SOMETHING.
WHEN YOU AND KATIE WERE WORKING
OUT, EVER MADE A BIG DEAL ABOUT
THE PHOTO.
NO ONE UNDERSTANDS WHAT THE OFF-
SEASON IN L.A.
IS LIKE, EDWARD IS WORKING OUT.
TALK ABOUT THAT MOMENT AND WHAT
IT WAS.
>> IT GOES BACK TO YOUR
QUESTION, WHAT DO YOU GIVE UP,
BEING JAYSON TATUM.
THEY EXAGGERATE EVERYTHING I DO.
I HAVE KNOWN KD SINCE HIGH
SCHOOL.
WE SPENT FIVE WEEKS TOGETHER
LAST YEAR FROM VEGAS TO TOKYO
AND WON A GOLD MEDAL.
WE HAVE A BOND.
THAT'S MY BROTHER.
IT'S LIKE, I'M NOT TOO PROUD TO
SAY THAT HE IS ONE OF THE BEST
PLAYERS EVER.
ONE OF THE BEST WANTS TO WORK
OUT WITH YOU, I COULD LEARN
THINGS FROM HIM.
WHY WOULD I SAY NO?
IF YOU WORRY ABOUT, IF YOU
WORRY TOO MUCH ABOUT WHAT OTHER
PEOPLE THINK, YOU ARE DRIVING
YOURSELF CRAZY.
IT IS CRAZY THAT I CAN'T WORK
OUT WITH MEONE.